el gobierno ruso ha dicho que no tiene
por qué dudar de la versión del
presidente bielorruso sobre el incidente
con el avión hoy alexandr lukashenko
líder de bielorrusia por fin ha dado la
cara ante el parlamento defendiendo que
en todo momento actuó conforme a la
legalidad a la hora de interceptar ese
avión y que lo hizo para salvar las
vidas de los pasajeros
lukashenko también ha adelantado que la
amenaza de bomba provenía de territorio
suizo
recordemos que en un primer momento el
gobierno bielorruso había dicho que
había sido la el colectivo islamista
hamás quien había amenazado de bomba a
ese avión en un email
lukashenko también ha sido muy crítico
con los gobiernos occidentales a los que
ha acusado de estar programando una
injerencia en su país y también ha
acusado al detenido a román portar
ceviche de estar preparando un baño de
sangre en territorio bielorruso